here's some of the tricks that our
friend 50 Cent has dated we talked about
Chelsea Handler used Goods we talked he
dated Vivica A fox gorgeous Paris Hilton
on the wrong side of 40 these days shout
out to her Sierra she's I think had a
kid with uh future and now she's has a
kid wiped up with Russell Wilson Now 50
Cent I believe is dating a girl called
Cuban Link but no doubt the wrong woman
will ruin your life I said this all the
time the right woman will improve your
life the wrong woman will ruin your life
I know there's some women out there that
can turn millionaires into billionaires
and either some will some women out
there that will make a millionaire or a
billionaire go broke Choose Wisely